okay as portrayed by Saturday Night Live
Eric Trump is often caricatured as the
dumbest son of Donald Trump I don't know
if that's accurate but Eric Trump
certainly is the most annoying to me if
you've seen him in television
appearances my prediction is you
probably agree if your sensibilities are
anything like mine and he did something
hilarious he went on Fox News obviously
where else is he going to go and he
advocated in favor of a very particular
type of regulation of websites like
Google and Facebook that is really
similar to something that net neutrality
advocates advocate doing for Internet
service providers but which Donald Trump
and his FCC have been diametrically
opposed to which is the idea of labeling
some of these big websites or Internet
service providers as utilities slash
what are called common carriers under
the 1934 Telecommunications Act so I'm
going to sort of really lay this out for
you as clearly as I can I want to set it
up for you okay one of the issues around
so-called censorship and free speech on
online platforms is very similar to a
net neutrality issue which is that of
title to common carriers so let's go
back to the beginning at a certain point
in time the country decided that things
like phone service for example are no
longer futuristic luxury technologies
but their utilities like electricity for
example or like internal plumbing water
and sewer service so they became
regulated under what's called title 2 of
the 1934 Telecommunications Act so one
of the strongest ways to support net
neutrality would be by adding Internet
Service Providers Internet service to
this list of services that's designated
as a common carrier and they should be
because at this point in time in the
United States the Internet is no longer
again
a futuristic luxury item it's used for
people's lives in every way for work for
getting a job for paying bills for
communicating with family I mean
everything is happening through the
internet even if you go to a store and
swipe your credit card a lot of those
transactions are now being verified
through the internet rather than over
phone lines as was originally the case
Republicans tend to be against that
those who immediately wanted a GTI FCC
Chairman under Trump to repeal Barack
Obama's net neutrality regulations don't
want Internet service providers
designated as common carriers so this is
very similar to the Facebook Twitter
Google censorship debate that a lot of
people are having wherein some believe
that Google and Twitter and Facebook are
just so big and they have such market
share that they can't be allowed to sort
of do whatever they want because they're
just private online companies they are
according to advocates of this ideology
sort of town square almost like
utilities and therefore they must be
regulated in a similar fashion to an isp
being regulated as a common carrier of
the utility that we call Internet
service that's the entire set up and I
know that that's a lot but it's
important to understand what I'm about
to show you
Eric Trump then goes on Fox News and he
goes on a mostly unintelligible rant
about censorship of conservatives on
social media but he does actually make
the claim that a lot of these tech
companies aren't really private
companies anymore that they have such
monopolistic market share and they are
so sort of integral to how people are
communicating and getting ideas out
there on the Internet that they are in a
sense beyond private companies and
should be governed by free speech like
utilities which is actually the word
that you'll hear Fox hosts Steve Doocy
mentioned at the end of the segment he
has clearly no idea that this is the
exact argument for net neutrality
internet service provider regulation as
common carriers he doesn't know that
ironic hilarious
here's Eric Trump on Fox News my
father's
social media director works in the white
house he got kicked off of Instagram
yesterday Miyuki Allah just yeah it was
a bot or an algorithm they always have
an excuse what can people actually do
north of the funnel promised the people
within these companies they are so much
on the opposite side that even when it
goes to a human to check writing you
want to keep certain things off you want
to keep certain things off right but
when it goes to a human to check you
know they see something that they don't
like they see a message a they don't
like and and that's why I mean it's
happened to everybody guys this happen
to Charlie Kurt it's had how do you fix
it
how do you fix it I don't know you know
others here saying the same thing three
weeks ago because he is being censored
I'd love to see this go to Supreme Court
to tell you through you know why or and
I think I think Kevin McCarthy I think
there are a lot of people who actually
want to do something about this but you
know they hide under the veil that well
we're private companies who are private
companies but you know what you're no
longer a private company when you are
monopoly when Facebook has 1.7 1.8
billion users around the world you're
beyond a private company you become a
monopoly and this is the exact argument
for saying when Comcast is the only game
in town and the Internet's used for
everything you're no longer just a
private company that can do whatever it
wants as Republicans want them to be
able to do you are a utility and there
need to be some restrictions as to what
you're allowed to do this is exactly the
type of thing that Obama was proposing
with ISPs
and Eric's dad came in and immediately
said I mean title two as common carriers
forget about it immediately said get rid
of all of that Obama net neutrality
stuff so a few things here first of all
I don't actually think Eric Trump really
has strong feelings one way or the other
in principle on this it's just about
what can I say right now that would be
good for my team he's not saying make
Comcast a public utility
he's saying make Facebook like a public
utility because he finds making Facebook
a public utility to be useful to getting
out positive things about Donald Trump
or stopping what he sees as conservative
censorship or whatever but the
underpinning values here are the same
for making both public utilities and I
actually argue the opposite which is it
is a stronger case to make the Internet
service provider a public utility than
an individual website like Facebook if
you want to make Facebook be regulated
like a public public utility of some
kind you have to I mean logically it
absolutely has to follow that as a
precursor to that the Internet service
provider being used to access Facebook
should obviously be regulated as a
public utility common-carrier under
title 2 I know Pat some people are going
to write to me and say Eric Trump isn't
actually saying that he's only talking
about Google and Facebook I understand
that he's not saying it because he
doesn't get it but the principle
underlying the idea of one is the exact
same principle underlying the idea of
Internet service providers as common
carriers he just isn't smart enough to
get it
well maybe strategically we should just
lay down here and let him have the wind
sort of play dumb right we can just say
oh I guess maybe social media sites are
disproportionately targeting
conservatives and social media sites are
the new public square and ISPs should be
added to the services designated as
common carriers just let Eric Trump have
the win on this one right yeah so hey
listen Eric you know what I want to work
with you to make sure conservatives
aren't being censored in any way and
that includes conservative websites that
includes conservative users of the
Internet so we'll make Facebook and
Google and Comcast and Verizon and all
of it will make all of them regulated
like public public utilities as a
footnote and I know that for most of our
audience I don't have to say this but
there's some interesting people that
watch our clips on YouTube it's not true
that online media companies are
censoring conservatives in any kind of
deliberate fashion you often hear that
twitter has a policy where if you
misgender individuals it's considered
harassment and you can get banned and
that that is considered some kind of
anti conservative bias there is a very
strong empirical case for why deliberate
misgendering is a form of bullying which
should be blocked by the terms and
conditions that twitter is completely
free to employ but that's sort of a
separate conversation it's not even
really the main interesting element of
what Eric Trump is
here so I'm not gonna go into it beyond
that but Eric Trump I imagine that if
you sat him down backstages at Eric
listen what you advocated for is exactly
the rationale that is being used to
advocate for Internet service providers
also being regulated in that way do you
understand that
my guess is he wouldn't get it and if he
did he wouldn't care because it's all
just about playing politics and trying
to support his team which right now I
would say it's the Republican Party but
it's kind of not even really it's just
the trumpian wing of the Republican
Party which is sizeable but it is not
all of it and that's the team they've
picked and that's the that they're going
down with the ship one way or the other
make sure you follow the David Pakman
show on instagram at david pakman show
follow me on instagram at David Pakman
we will take a quick break and be joined
by Erin Hamlin next to talk about
approval voting another voting method we
haven't talked too much about one of the
day's sponsors is privacy calm slash
Pakman which is a free service that I
myself use really useful in many
different ways takes just a few seconds
to link your debit card to privacy calm
then you can create virtual credit cards
that are linked directly to your bank
account and you use those virtual credit
card numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the Internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a David
Pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy comm icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm
there are a ton of advantages to using a
free service like this for example you
can sign up for as many free trials as
you want then just delete the virtual
credit card you used and never worry
about getting charged for it it protects
you from getting hacked it protects you
when companies are hacked which happens
all the time
it is all completely free all you have
to do is click the link under this video
to get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link